i'm sorry mark
all right lisa yes sir lisa where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
what happened
where are you from originally artesia
california here in los angeles somewhere
no rtj california yes
valflower
norway south of l.a yes sir artesia arta
tell me about your family
my family
not much of a family
my mom had her favorite
i was not a favorite
but i took care of her up until her last
breath
and uh
they're both buried together
the favorites
but i i survived
were you the black sheep of your family
outcast
yes
outcast
i'm not a black sheep okay i'm an
outcast
what uh what was your childhood like in
general how would you describe it oh
[ __ ]
i didn't mean to say that but i had to
get it out
oh it was horrible
i just told you
my mom did not
respect me
or
in her own way but god bless her
and my dad was not there he left when i
was seven years old and
i basically raised myself
any abuse
yes
mentally and emotionally but no
physically
you judge me i'm gonna fight you back
you started drinking at some point
i'm sorry you started drinking alcohol
at some point yeah at 16 years old 16
yes you took to it
yes i did
that's what took fear away
and i could become invisible
fearless
i mean i i felt it
it's an escape
has alcohol helped you over the long
haul
or the big picture it's not really
helping me
nowadays
but
it helped me in a sense to
think that i was more powerful
that i could take a punch
or what abuse it went through
because it helped me to numb myself
you took a punch recently it looks like
yes
and it's stabbing
stabbing too what happened
oh your arm that's a pretty bad wound on
your arm yeah he stopped me
was a knife
so but anyway i'm here so who who hit
you he stabbed you
i cannot say shout there oh i see he
will hit me again
so i keep it out low
but uh
guess who's gonna stab me next god
no dear children listen yes
my daughter is 35 and my son is 33
and they're awesome
i wasn't there for them that's what made
them stronger
in their life
because we can't wipe their asses all
over their life
they have to become strong who raised
your kids mostly
um
well it was
me
until her father died
and then
their mother-in-law
until she died
i got him back
but a lot of things happened they were
teenagers and running wild
and then their uncle
in tennessee
right you were drinking back then too
hell yeah
i go hell yeah
i didn't mean to say like that it's the
truth
yes
i've been drinking all my life dude
but there were points in my life where i
stayed sober
and i know what recovery is about
i'm looking at your
readings on the wall
and
i'm very curious woman
even though i drink
i still keep my
posture about me
and i do have dignity
i'm not the best but i'm not the worst
you get it i do
i like you're smart
where do you live now where do you stay
in a tent still i'm waiting on my
housing my case manager just came and
seen me
she put in a referral for me to get
healthy
she's very kind to me
i don't know why but
along the way when i'm walking down the
street
there are little things like miracles
that come my way
i don't want to say it
but he keeps on taking everything away
from me
but guess what it's okay because
i
have faith
i might drink
but i still haven't
i am me
dear friends
not true friends
i know what a true friend is
a friend in need is friend indeed
the friends are the ladies
who give me
a dress
when i didn't have nothing
those are friends but i don't associate
too much you look beautiful today i'm
sorry you look beautiful today oh thank
you i don't feel beautiful oh you're
beautiful in blue maybe i go get more
beautiful yeah
where do you get your clothes
the women's center they give them out
people donate yeah yeah
yeah the community down here is so
well-dressed because of
all the donations that yes
oh i know a lot of people
ellie ken
you know ellie count no
yeah adam and jennifer
adam gave me my fifth tent
no i don't want him to hear me
oh i can't beat him
tell me about living in a tent on skid
row
it's it's hard
but it is livable
because the fact is
i have to survive
in my way
how do you make money to survive i'm
sorry how do you make money to survive
i don't get money
i go
to places that give out free food
and clothes
why do i need money what's up
drinks
all that
i forgot
i can't handle
yeah
hey
can i have some change don't give me
five dollars at mcdonald's
oh do you talk with your family still
no
more dead
what about your kids
i'm sorry your kids yeah but i don't
have a phone now of course i talk to
them
i know my son's number by heart
he is beautiful
so is my daughter i would not allow her
to be out here
she is gorgeous
felicia ann maxwell and
she's my firstborn
and she's gorgeous i would not ever
bring her out here for have you been
married before you been in love
yeah when i was 16.
but yeah i've been married twice they're
both deceased
don't get me wrong i didn't i didn't do
it
oh god bless this was the best time of
your life the best years
your best memories i don't think i ever
had the best year
to be honest
i can't remember because
i've been through a lot of suffering
right now
and
then
let me tell you something
for the best
it wasn't a year it was a moment
when i was married to my first husband
he was so good to me i don't know what
he's seen in me
i kiss his toes because they're cute
no i don't want to talk about him
but
that was the best moment
not a year
it's been the roughest time of your life
i'm sorry it's been the hardest time of
your life right now right now
yes how old are you now
i am coming up on 58
i'm old as [ __ ]
i'm not sweet 16 anymore
yes this has been the worst
being down here is a
woman is it difficult i'm sorry being a
woman here on skid row
you should answer that question
i proven that am i not
look at the scars yeah
that happens a lot i think
yes
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
i would have
went to college
got a degree
and raised my kids rightly
and treated them rightly and me rightly
yes
i would give
them the bedrooms and me the sofa with
my little kitty
yeah
it's called memories
what are you afraid of now
i said it
yeah
i'm sorry
i just
i don't want him to hear me
he'll get mad
do you have hope for the
do you have hope for your future
oh yeah i always keep hope
if i lose hope i'll lose it
i'll lose me what would you like where
would you like to be in five years
hey i'm on a mansion
no i'd like to be
teaching others
how to survive
and giving them hope
because
a lot of us are hopeless
we feel hopeless i meant to say
i've taken back
but
i would like to encourage them that
there is hope
i never lost hope
it's with me right now
hope is right here hope's important
yes fairy
hope
what is your drink what do you like to
drink
well i love to drink beer this is my
specialty
i need a drink
how many beers a day will you drink
i will drink all day but i don't get
drunk anymore
but it's funny
i used to be a blackout drinker but now
i don't do that
i'm very
your body's gotten used to it i watch my
my agenda
i have to
has alcohol would you say alcohol has
ruined your life or oh yes
oh yes
because i allowed it to yeah
was there anyone else in your family
that was an alcoholic
yes
maybe it's genetic
yes
i hear you
i'm sorry what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret is
god is painful
is um
not being there for my kids
because of my alcoholism
and that is the truth
nothing but the truth
so help me god
lisa what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
58 years
i've learned how to survive
in sufferings
and caring
and
now i'm learning how to respect people
because they deserve it no matter what
they call me
i've learned a lot
because i'm teachable now
god has shown me things
that i never experienced before
and it's a beautiful thing
even though i drink
all right lisa thank you so much for
sharing your story i love you i wish you
the best of luck out there
you